here's a reminder Philadelphia beat  Washington by a score of 24 to 16 last  Sunday  you gonna need a bigger potion I didn't  find any boat rental and charter  services oh yeah you can milk anything  with nipples I have nipples Greg could  you milk me I found 15 groceries 14 of  them are fairly close to you it's  Thursday November 21st 2013 somebody  please give me directions where would  you like to go what you got a class to  seek the Holy Grail what is the airspeed  velocity of an unladen swallow about 25  miles per hour for a European swallow  you have to know these things when  you're a virtual assistant you know play  as time goes by I couldn't find it  sampling as time goes on your music  because it comes down to a simple choice  really get busy later  you get busy time I don't know how to  respond to that  note to self I don't want to live  Gary's Ranaut I don't want to live okay  here's a place matching the chopper it  looks pretty close to you